dave it's been a while welcome back to
computer file hello
thanks for joining us i thought it'd be
worth telling the story of
um a little mess around project that you
and i did we were discussing
a logo design or a design for something
and we talked about the idea of a wave
file or an audio file because audio is
why i come to you and um to cut a very
long story short and
so so we can get into the actual code of
it and everything
we talked about the idea of turning
audio
from a v from a visual or a wave
representation
back into audio so this is kind of like
the world's worst
sampling project right yes or how not to
sample
i think i said one of your one of your
most popular videos is uh how not to
store passwords and i i remember saying
texting you and saying we should call
this how not to sample
so let me just talk through the workflow
if that's
not too grandiose a term for this so i
recorded
me saying this computer file
so that's what it looked like on the
audio recorder i used
you sent me a screen grab of it and you
were saying maybe in your logo have a
wave and then
you wrote me as a bit of a joke
something along the lines oh there'll be
extra points
if you can get the audio back out of
this wave call it a challenge or
something like that you said it's a
challenge
and i said all right challenge taken so
anyone watching this who's a great
programmer don't judge the code this was
a kind of like a 25 minute trying to
quickly rush it out and get you back an
audio file as quick as possible so you
sent me a high quality version of it and
i
kind of i was it was just a bit of fun
we were having during uh during 2020.
2020 fun so how did you go about it then
what
so um if i turn around to the side here
a second i'll i'll uh
get onto the screen so basically i'll
load up the
picture that you sent me so here's the
picture that you sent me
and the first thing i wanted to do was
get rid of the adobe
audition stuff around it so i put it
into photoshop and
i kind of got the what the color of the
green of the grid behind and basically
removed all of that
until it became this so you can see
we're pretty much left with just a black
background and the wave
so in in a previous video i think it's
my first ever computer file video we
talked about how
computers sample audio and basically
you're drawing a graph
of the uh the pressure waves in the air
then that graph
obviously can be shown on the screen and
you're sending me a picture of that
graph which is
obviously losing a huge amount of detail
and then i'm trying to reconstruct an
audio file that we can listen to
back from that so i was looking at it
and thinking all i'm really interested
in on the kind of like the vertical
lines of the picture
is to look at where the top and the
bottom
pixels are the the the bright points
and basically have a min and a max for
each
vertical line i keep wanting to say
horizontal but it's it's vertical
that was my first way of doing it i'm
sure there's loads of ways of doing it
and loads of people are going to leave
comments saying oh you should have done
it like this and this was just a bit of
fun that we we did so i've got here the
code i load in the bitmap the file is
called computerfile.png
and then i create a new bitmap this is
all in c sharp by the way
i create a list of values which is the
values i'm going to get out of the
bitmap
and then we go around in a loop here for
the width
of the bitmap so i go from zero to one
before the width
and then basically i set what my max and
my min and this looks a bit weird
because i've got my mac set to zero and
i've got my minimum
set to the height which seems like the
wrong way around but
that will make sense in a minute so this
piece of code here
goes up each column of the picture it's
going from the bottom to the top
on each one eventually spit out the
minimum and the maximum value of each
one so obviously here the minimum
is going to be down here and the maximum
is going to be right up here whereas
here the minimum is going to be here and
the maximum is going to be here so
they're going to be different values
in each column in the picture you can
see here
that because a lot of it is just a solid
block of color
there's no actual wave data
in that at all there's nothing we can
get from that so all i'm doing is kind
of going well i want the bottom
there and the top there i just want to
know what those values are and i'm not
really interested in
what the shape would be in the middle of
that because we don't know that that
would just be guesswork and i fill that
in later
so the way i do that is with this bit of
code here
which goes up each column and basically
i set the max to zero and the minimum to
the
the maximum height and then we go
through and we basically
we're challenging the maximum and
minimum we're saying well is this new
value
pick the new value the smallest one of
these two and obviously at the moment
our minimum is set to the maximum it can
be the fullest height
so if the value i'm getting is smaller
than that then it will reset the minimum
and then as you iterate through each
pixel you're going to extract the
minimum and the maximum values
from here now i'm telling whether a
pixel is is the green by its brightness
so i'm going to get the pixel at the
point x and y
and if the brightness is over 0.5 which
is a scale from 0 to 1
then i'm saying it's not part of the
background it's part of the graph
for each column i'm saying i want the
minimum maximum minimum maximum minimum
maximum all the way across
the picture and basically creating a
list
of numbers you know which is all an
audio sample it's just a list of numbers
then i made this kind of a filter here
which actually just passes a
moving average over the whole thing
which just smooths it out a bit and
basically stop the ringing from the
sampling errors i then purely so i can
plot the graph
i'm going to show you next output each
of the values to a text file
here's the text file so you get all of
those values here
and then of course we can move over to
libra office
and actually plot them on a graph which
is there so you that was a way of me
checking it was all working and doing
what i wanted it to do
of course if i played this if i
converted this straight to a wav
file it would go clever and it would be
gone whereas you're
saying computer file or computer file
but it's
a bit fun that would be far too quick
because
in each one of those columns there's
probably a lot more columns because the
picture you gave me was very very
squashed in so i needed to stretch it
and of course depending on the picture
that you give me and how
zoomed in or out it was that stretch
amount will change so i had to
experiment with that until i got it to
something that i thought sounded like
your real voice
so here i open a new file to write out
this wav file i've got a load of wave
header
stuff going on there the bytes that you
write for the header of away file to say
that it's 8 bit or 16 bit or what the
frequency is and
sample frequency and everything so and
then i've got this stretch value
that i've set myself to 9 which will
elongate or
squash up the wave as i want and then
down here for each of the value as i'm
writing it out i go round in a loop
around the amount of stretches i want
and i basically add in new data
so if i'm going from this point to this
point but i want nine places in between
so basically what you're having is
you've got a minimum maximum value and
in between
you're getting a little bit of one and a
lot of the other and then as you're
moving through that increment the the
the proportion between the waiting is
going between the two
and in this case i'm doing it in a way
that's very very crude you know you
might want to do it in a more kind of
curved way with signs
but again this was just a quick
programming challenge from you over
over whatsapp when we were having a
having a conversation so for each of
those values i write out
value three which is the intermediate
point and i write that out as the file
and then finally i set the last value to
whatever the current value is and it
goes back around the loop so that it's
got
the previous value up here i actually
set the last value to zero so i
initialize the
variable to zero so it starts at zero
and then it
closes the file and it it was just that
simple and i thought i wonder
whether this could work obviously i
didn't write it all in one go like that
i wrote out and plotted the graph and
i did it first and heard that it was
squashed up and realized i needed to
scratch and stretch it and add it all in
i mean
there was a it's an iterative process i
wasn't just
you know write it all out and once and
hit go and it all just worked magically
but and
much as these things seem like that
sometimes it definitely wasn't but um
yeah and i was i was really sort of
blown away by how how well it worked to
be honest i didn't expect it to work as
well as it did
i've got audacity here i can drag over
the newly generated wave file
and we can hit play
when i first heard this it just reminded
me of the sort of sampling that we got
in 8-bit video games back in the day so
i remember playing a game on the
commodore 64 back in the 1980s
which had some speech synthesis on it
and it sounded like that
um some of that was was two bit and four
bit i mean they were really
really simple i don't know what my acorn
electron was running back in the days
but yeah i mean it's it's
effectively your your you're in audio
terms as
as someone who's more of a sort of an
audio engineer in this kind of thing
um if i wanted to get that sound let's
say i was doing a recording and someone
said i want that sound on my voice i
wouldn't code something i'd grab
a bit crusher or something that's going
to distort it where it's going to square
things off and it's going to
effectively so obviously if you've got a
nice smooth wave
you want to have as many levels as
possible within that wave so that you've
got a nice kind of a
gradation of different different volumes
effectively that's what you're measuring
of different voltages
um and the the more bits you have
to to represent that you know
exponentially gets bigger and bigger and
the more the more detail you can have so
eight bits is is
can is so much worse than 16 bits it's
ridiculous and four bits again is so
much worse than
eight bits so and we're extracting
something here that
realistically i mean i've converted it
to 8-bit but whether i was even close to
getting that kind of quality in the
first place i mean i i wouldn't i
haven't even
bothered even thought to try and work
out what the source file
bit rate could possibly be the list of
numbers straight off the picture file
is presumably a tiny amount of data it's
a 35k
file with the numbers and that's of
course written in ascii that's not in
in in binary which would be
yeah a hell of a lot smaller that was
just written in a text file from it to
me to whacking to make a spreadsheet but
um
i mean i think with all of these things
with any format if you're converting
data from one place to another there
will be a way that
it seems to fit sort of in its smallest
sense and more naturally
but there will be um
you should be able to represent data in
any way i mean i've seen videos on
computer file we've talked about you
know storing data in photos
you know we know with with modems and
other such things you know that
data all the time is being transmitted
via audio and via light with optical
signals so
whether it's the most natural format for
for that or not is a
different thing but bottom line is they
all come down to a list of numbers
at the end of the day everything becomes
a list of numbers you know
this whole exercise though then brought
up a really interesting question
uh for me which which was so let's say
i bought a stock photo on a stock photo
website of a producer standing in front
of a mixing desk and on the screen
behind him
he had a picture of a wave file and
i've bought the rights to use that
picture and any derivative works from it
so if i then reverse engineer the audio
from that picture can i use the audio
because it came from the picture which
i've had the rights to get
derived works from which could be a real
problem for let's say sound on sound
magazine
interviewing a famous producer and he's
got a multi-track of one of his clients
up on the screen in the background
i mean if you had a really high
resolution picture of that you know you
might be able to get out some artist
single before it's been released to the
you know to the market there's some
really interesting questions that come
out of this that i think you know in
some ways are more interesting than the
quite simple code i suspect that the
only one who's ever going to benefit
from that is a lawyer's uh
bank balance to be honest well if
there's a lawyer out there that watches
this channel then uh then leave us a
comment and tell us whether
whether that would uh cause any problems
or not
we're not going to pay you though we're
not paying you for legal advice
if anything this might just expose the
accuracy of
adobe's wave to graphics
capabilities in the first place that
overview
i'm using the word overview because
that's what it would be called in in
kind of
logic or cubase or anything like that
but that overview that they're writing
if you've got a really really smooth
curve and then you squash it up and you
physically haven't got enough pixels on
your screen to represent
that um that curve then
you're by doing the zooming of the wave
you're
basically throwing away information
yourself and reducing the quality of it
and then when i restretch it i'm having
to fill that in so
we're going to lose high frequency data
there also by squashing it that way
we're going to lose
um bit depth on it so there's there's so
much that's that's lost from that but
the the fascinating thing for me was the
fact that what we recovered was still
perfectly audible actually they've done
a pretty good job of it
yeah yeah i mean it's it has to be good
enough to use and i think
like anything when you do when you're
designing a piece of software
you want to write something that's going
to give you enough of the wave
that it's going to be good enough to the
user
but not so much of the wave that it's
going to eat up processing power when
you're trying to redraw and you want to
quickly zoom in and out of stuff so
obviously what what you're seeing there
without what you're discussing there is
the natural trade-off between those two
things so
clearly what they're giving you is good
enough for you to do your work
and good enough for us to actually
recreate what you said from it you know
which which is good how's that old
camera that i uh
sold you getting on it's wonderful and
it's so lovely that your older
canon c100 is going to make its way back
onto computer file
but i am still getting adjusted with
looking at the camera and i've got you
down here on whatsapp are used to people
not looking at the camera anyway
yeah that's fair enough